to be here I've been trying to think
about a lot of different directions of
where I wanted to go with this talk I'm
very obsessed with the word context if
it's my single favorite word in the
world I think people pay way too much
attention to content which is massively
important and I think a lot of us for
content is King and all those kind of
things but I I really do believe that
context is the signals that one word in
the world we live in now because there's
so much noise and understanding the room
or the platform or the nuances of the
event or anything in life is massively
important so the context of this talk is
super important to me because a lot of
you are in a different chapter live your
lives then let's say a lot of the
audiences that I normally talk to so I'm
gonna take a little bit of a different
turns with this with this talk today so
I suck [ __ ] at 99.9% of the things in
the world and that's like a fun thing to
giggle at but it's actually shockingly
true I was a I was a solid at student in
school and I'm not kidding like I think
when I tell people that I was a DNF
student people laughed like haha because
they've had success and they think I
mean B's and C's no I mean like these
maps right I was really bad at school
mainly because since the time I can
remember which is like you know three
I've always wanted to sell stuff right
I'm a business man through and through
and I think about why have I been able
to be successful even though everything
that led up to let's say when I was 18
years old on paper traditionally the way
we score lend itself to make people
believe that I wasn't going to be
successful and then started thinking
about the world you live in and then I
started thinking about wow you know I'm
living in 1% life I'm financially
ridiculously secure I'm I'm right now
focused on buying the New York Jets
right so literally on
I'm a millionaire I've got all these
great things and why am I sitting back
there and willing to give up everything
that I've achieved over the last 20
years to call it to trade places with
any one of the people in this room and I
was think about why is that and why is
that really true and I'm not kind of
like giving you like [ __ ] ago I wish
it was you like I really mean it and the
reason is because what I've realized was
holy crap we live in the most ridiculous
ridiculous era of all time this is what
I mean the cost the infrastructure cost
to do what you want to do is very light
has collapsed over the last ten years
there's this thing another thing I've
heard about it you may want to write
this down there's this thing called the
Internet right and it's something that
wasn't important
or really at scale when I was your age
only 15 years ago right and you know
really the internet took off in the US
when mint Windows 95 came out and so
it's really only been about 17 years
that the Internet has been a consumer
facing product and only really over the
last five to 10 at scale what the
Internet has done not Facebook or
Twitter or tumblr or Pinterest or
Instagram or snapchat but the Internet
itself has done is created a scenario
where there's really little to no reason
unless you sit through all of today I'm
gonna apologize I might ruin the whole
day here right now so pay attention to
where I'm going with this
unleash your obnoxious lis obsessed with
the organization and more person during
the rest of the thing today I can you
have this seriously debate where you are
in your life right now and give enormous
thought to try to make the thing that
you love the most in the world work for
you meaning there is never like as much
as I'd love to right now like room up
with like four of my buddies you sleep
on the floor and you [ __ ] chicken
nuggets 24 hours
it's just not that practical meanwhile
it's ridiculously practical for you
right now a lot of you could have
brought up in a way to be practical a
lot of you who's been brought up in a
way to have security and do the thing
that you're supposed to do and have had
a lot of mentors parents teachers you
know tell you about the way it's going
to be or should be but I highly
massively this single reason I woke up
today and have none and don't do the
weekend events because that's my family
time and woke up this morning and got
here today was to tell you one thing
which is I recommend it it's very
seriously
that you go home and think about the
fact that you should probably allocate
the next three to four years of your
life to try to execute on the thing that
you want to do for the [ __ ] rest of
your life and the reason that is is
because you're in just the morning the
reason that this is you can just afford
starting at zero at 26 and 27 you just
can now you might not be scrappy enough
like you might want [ __ ] like you might
want a [ __ ] purse right like high
like you might write like and that's
cool like that's what you like and if
that's what you needed then go get a
[ __ ] job right like I get that but if
you really want to do little thing that
drives you that's when you get into the
zone of like cool I don't need to live
in the best place cool I'll commute from
a little further away cool I'll team up
with four or five people have to sleep
on a couch and I think that that to me
is the part that's most interesting the
reason I'm willing to trade is because I
know how awesome it feels to do what you
love it's what I've been able to do my
whole life and for me that is something
that there's absolutely no price on and
more importantly the ability to go
practical and two or three or four years
is so easy and so recently recently
something weird happened I'm doing this
thing where I'm doing an interview every
day this will we are 365 interviews
every day with people that have been
advanced
my work swimmingly really small blogs
like my PR people and all my managers
and handlers are really pissed at me
because they're like why are we spending
15 minutes doing these blogs that have
six readers you know every single day
and you're passing on the stuff that
we're giving you to be on CNN or New
York Times and the answer is because
there's two different very different
things you can do for meaning at South
by Southwest is here instead of giving a
keynote to 4,000 people like I'd
normally have I set up a kissing booth
style thing that was a Q&A booth and I
stood in a booth five hours and I
answered every person's question one by
one by one and it took me 15 minutes per
person so only not to like 200 people
but those two other people I had a much
deeper connection with right and so it
all talked about like you know quality
versus quantity right do you want to go
wider do you want to go deep and I've
been thinking a lot more about that and
I think that what ended up happening was
I wanted to go deeper with my community
I wanted to give back to people that
were fans of me and so if they could
leverage my name to build up their blogs
that's why I'm doing it not because I
want something for myself
I'm gonna get mine I always get my right
this was about me kind of giving back a
little bit and so that's why I'm doing
it and I did this interview and in it I
kind of went on this rant that I'm
giving you right now and I said
something and I've never said it before
because I'm complete improv I've no
[ __ ] idea what I'm about to say for
the next ten minutes for example and and
I said something that really kind of
stuck and then the guy kind of took a
made a poster out of it or I'm a piece
of micro contact and put it out there
and it's kind of quite viral him in and
I said I actually don't care about your
next ten years I care about the last ten
years so let me tell you something
really [ __ ] weird about me I'm
obsessed with very old people
like when I travel which is almost all
the time I often be like literally in an
airport roll up on some poor like 80
year old couple and sit down and start
bothering now right and the reason I do
that often is I found something point I
just think it's really fascinating when
you talk to a 70 80 90 year old person
right it's really fascinating because
you start realizing what they're focused
on and I haven't I've never heard a 9
year old person ever say they wish they
made their money never ever zeros and
the things you hear are always very
similar which is they wish they did like
one guy caught me off guard really like
conservative looking dude we start
talking a little bit he looked me in the
face he goes I wish I didn't work at
that [ __ ] factory for 50 years I
start laughing but it really hit home
and then a lot of people also talk about
how much they wish they spent more time
with their family and so you start
realizing like if these people played
the game then why are we not listening
to them listen does the second you
breathe their first breath you want I
don't know all your circumstances or any
of you were playing this country the
second year born in America you [ __ ]
won right when you put it into context
about what's going on out there it is
ridiculous the opportunity we have now
because not only all the business is in
place and all the things that can be
done but it has never been cheaper or
more practical to try to build a career
for yourself because of the
infrastructure of the internet so for me
what's most fascinating about everybody
that's sitting in this room is how
fertile and opportunistic this next
chapter is for you and what I really
worry about is a lot of you looking back
in 30 40 50 60 years and thinking back
to this exact speech and save yourself
when I [ __ ]
to him because what you have right now
in timing and circumstance is this
ridiculous ridiculous 50 month window to
not be practical 50 month window to not
do it the way you thought you were
always going to do it 50 month window
yeah if you go for this as much as you
possibly go for it that if you decide
you gave it a good shot and you felt
good about it that if you started then
becoming practical you'd be far less
behind than you think
see that's the dirty little secret right
the payoff or the thing that really
scares you about well let me try and
start my own blog or my own business or
my own thing with my friends is that you
think that well if it doesn't work I
don't want to be 27 and have given up
those four years the reality is is if
you're good if you've got chops if
you've got any skills it's not going to
matter because the 12 months after you
prove yourself within whatever we're
going to say should you go in and be
practical
you'll be exactly where you're supposed
to be and so that is the dirty little
secret the dirty little secret is that
you have a full day of people here
peering what they do and PR and where
they work hopefully require to bring
young talent that's in the room and the
only reason I think people should work
for me very honestly and vaynermedia is
because what I'm willing to do for them
individually within or outside my
organization once they come in because
what I realized a couple years ago is
everything else is a commodity
everything else is a commodity having a
couple of years on your resume from some
[ __ ] agency or media company is a
[ __ ] commodity but it's not a
commodity it's the relationships new
people and the individuals that can
actually guide you to the place you want
to be so what are basically telling you
here today is [ __ ] everything you hear
give serious serious thought to like
what does that really could do what you
wanted to do what would you do recognize
that it's never been cheated ever been
cheaper to be able to achieve that or do
that recognize that the far majority of
the people among the panels today are
working for companies that have
disrupted traditional media companies or
agencies at far less costs right when
you look at the Thrillist or Huffington
Post or daily kami or all these
platforms
I mean Perez Hilton with no money years
ago before the internet really was at
scale with a bigger media company than
Us Weekly at a point and it was zero
dollars I sure a lot of you that
probably don't know I come from the wine
business more people were watching my
wine shows than the being the Wine
Spectator and they were the leader for
30 years in spends millions of dollars
building that business I just put up a
good content on YouTube and used Twitter
and Facebook to promote it it's just
different that's it the reason I switch
with you is it's just different like I
wish that I had the scale and the
breadth of opportunity
I wish that I had the real opportunity
that you guys do just do I mean I think
it's very cliche and I'm sure you people
you know you hear it and I don't want
something cold dude telling you like
that's what you know it is but it's what
it is and so that's going to kind of
fascinated by which is I'm far more
interested in like what do you love more
than life like what would you truly do
if you hit the [ __ ] lotto and good
like do whatever you want and just did
it every day what is that and I behind
me with all my heart soul recommend
taking a very serious book about taking
that at-bat and trying to do that for
the next couple years and the only
reason not to is if somebody captivates
you today with their organization or who
they are individually that's it it's
really that quite simple I farm rather
new Q&A right now with you guys and
answer questions then talk about
anything else because really
fundamentally I don't think anything
else is that important right there's
plenty of things going on you know
social media is [ __ ] rad you know but
there's a ton of stuff going on but the
truth real fundamental thing that you
need to think about is that because when
I did write rush yet which was 2008 it
was harder not easier there was harder
for years ago to do what I wrote about
that book and that's what I'm talking to
you about right now which is if you have
expertise or passion around the subject
matter like there was no [ __ ] way to
make money fifteen years ago about
loving Millie [ __ ] Vanilli right but
some dude this year is going to make
$100,000 a year for [ __ ] loving
Trinidad James and 2 Chainz
it's just gonna happen and that's a real
thing and so that's something I think
you guys need to think about because
really very honestly I'm giving this
talk to one person some one person in
this room I actually at some level and
hope to giving this talk to one person
in this room I know that I know that
very few people here are going to
actually take that at bat idea because I
understand all the scary reasons and you
know one talks not going to change you
know twenty years of structure and
thought process and what even has been
sold to you the whole way through
however I'm praying one person listens
for them being selfish I'm looking
forward to in four years to get that
email that says thank you and I was in
the crowd and I listened to you and I'm
a doctor thousand dollars a year talking
about showing that James I really get
scared because I said to talk about it I
always wonder like what you're thinking
right I was thinking about like do you
think I'm straight full of [ __ ] do you
think it's not practical at all do you
think it's like my see going this route
do you think like that's fine but that's
not real it's just it's just something
that I'm scared about because it's so
obvious to me it makes me so sad that we
don't have the structure now that a lot
of people work in places they work
because they have student loans that
taught them nothing that's actually
practical about the way the world
actually is it scares me that I failed
every one of my [ __ ] classes and I
traveled the country speaking at Harvard
and Yale and the university should kind
of a business school and I walk in there
and listen to the lecture before I speak
always to get a little context and the
[ __ ] professors lost lost because the
world is completely different in the
last three years than it was three years
ago the rules different than it was six
months ago
I spent 24 hours a day and I pure talent
for what consumers want and how to self
I spent 24 hours a day paying attention
and it's different than it was six
months ago so how the [ __ ] is some book
gonna teach people and so I think about
that all the time I think about how the
world in the system really is I think
about like why was I have student
because I promise you if there was a
business school for K through 12 right
here's my thing right if you would have
taught me why New Coke failed in 1984
and 5th brain I'm gonna get an egg
instead you wanted to teach me how many
[ __ ] rings around Saturn and that's
it right and I think we all know this
and I think you know it I just think
it's scary I I guess I would tell you
that doing what you love is the number
one thing that ever happened to you it's
far better than stuff and if there's any
way that I can convince you to just go
for it for the next three or four years
which is going to eliminate stuff and
it's gonna limiting fun stuff like going
out right like with your friends or like
vacations or like it's not just [ __ ]
purses but but I highly recommend giving
it thought because the stakes are high
and and the reason the other people
around you that you look up to unless
you have young older slightly older
brothers and sisters is they didn't have
it like your parents didn't have this
true infrastructure to take that at bat
it's not that they're long it just
didn't happen but she didn't happen it
wasn't practical being ambitious for
what you want to do and taking a net
back but actually doing it is actually
practical now she says nothing you know
the way entrepreneurs took shots back in
the day is they borrowed hundreds of
thousands of dollars to start something
that was physical and 99% of
business the cost that you're going to
put into trying to do your own thing
it's just going to be your time and the
number one thing that you have right now
over means bless you the number one
thing you have over me right now is your
time that's what I was going to trade
with you because time is the biggest
most valuable asset in the world and for
all the cash and [ __ ] and connections
that I have
I can't trade that for time and so I
highly recommend you take advantage of
the thing that you have that so few
other people have which is the ability
to go do something right now and then
time to actually execute it and then if
you're going to be practical find a
place that you'd be inspired find a
place that the people within that
organization actually give a [ __ ] about
who you are with them with within and
without inner walls of that organization
and be very strategic about it take a
little less money to get the right
mentorship and stepping stones because
I'm obsessed with taking one step back
for two steps forward way too many
people take the best looking thing at 23
and 22 and then at 25 the game's changed
and so really give that a lot of thought
as well I would highly recommend
auditing the opportunity predicated on
three or four years from now not for the
next 12 months I'm very very important
it's all I've decided I'd much rather do
Q&A it's just pretty good at whose tips
you don't have to come up here to just
raise your hand I'll repeat it but I'd
love to do some Q&A please don't be
scared and thank you for having me thank
you
a few minutes
you